Welcome friends. Whether you're out on a
walk,
running errands, or relaxing at home,
it's wonderful to connect with you.
Joining us today is Reverend Jocelyn
Jones.
Reverend Jocelyn Jones is a speaker,
two-time best-selling author, and
Christian business coach
who helps purpose-driven women turn their
calling
into sustainable, impactful businesses.
Reverend Jocelyn, welcome to Phoenix in
Flame.
Thank you so much for having me.
~ it's a joy.
This is gonna be fun. This is gonna be
fun.
So gosh, where do I even begin?
You later on in your bio, you talk about
helping women gain clarity,
build structure. I mean, it just goes on
and on.
I've got all kinds of questions,
but let me kind of back away and give you
some space to just kind of tell
us a little bit about yourself.
And you can start wherever you would like.
Some people really like stories from the
very beginning that that
really are impactful to them. Some people
want to start later,
but wherever you start, we'll end up
weaving wherever we need to weave
in the conversation. So what tell us a
little bit about you and
why why this interest? How did you get to
this place?
Thank you, Dana. Well, I I tell you,
it's been quite the journey. And for me,
I have been working in full-time ministry
since the age of 23.
And I was offered an opportunity to work
at my church at the nonprofit youth
center,
and I became the executive director there.
For about 10 years, I served diligently,
and it was very rewarding work.
But have you ever had that time in your
life where even though what
you were doing was rewarding?
You knew you were in the right season at
some point,
but you knew that season was coming to an
end.
And I felt like God was calling me to
more.
I felt like God was calling me to build
something beyond the walls
of the church that was ministry,
but it looked different. And I didn't
quite know how that looked.
But over time I you know, I prayed,
I fasted, went to seminary school trying
to find myself and you know,
eventually I I made the decision to step
out of
The box, if you will, and start my
ministry that we're gonna talk about
today.
And it started off as a blog, me writing
stories about how God helped people
to heal from trauma. And I published that
weekly on Fridays,
calling it Faith Fridays. And then over
time I started writing books and podcasts.
But what really was a life-changing moment
for me,
someone invited me to a Christian trauma
healing group.
It was a Bible study that included mental
health.
Health principles to help people heal from
trauma.
And it was in March of 2020, right at the
beginning
Mm.
of COVID. You know exactly what was
happening then.
And
Mm-hmm.
I have a background in social work.
I have my MSW and my master's in theology.
And when I saw this curriculum,
I was like, this is amazing. This combines
both my loves.
And I started doing that on Zoom because
we were all locked down.
But because I started doing these
regularly on Zoom,
that allowed for me to connect with people
across the country who were looking
for healing, who wanted connection.
And that over time allowed for me to grow
my ministry from that blog
to national Christian trauma healing
business over the last several years.
And from that, that's when I connected
with other women who wanted to learn
how to start their faith-based ministry in
business.
And that's when that second arm began of
me supporting other women.
I love this so much. And I already have so
many questions for you.
And and before I have several already
written down,
but before I get to those, as you were
just describing this,
I'm thinking of a lot of people that are
that are in church.
~ I I grew up in church myself and I'm a
Christian.
it's I don't know,
it seems easier for people sometimes when
they're following the status quo.
When they're following the path that seems
to be the vanilla path,
which is not the path I've taken,
by the way. ~ but I'm not a vanilla kind
of gal,
but ~ it just seems like ~ it's easier
sometimes,
it seems easier when people are following
the path that everyone seems
to be doing and that everyone seems to
expect them to do too.
And
when God kind of calls you to take the
exit,
to go somewhere else, ~ I think of like,
for example, like Jonah. ~ you know,
he didn't want to go to Nineveh.
He's like, I ain't going to Nineveh,
no way. Uh-uh, I'm doing that.
But we saw, we know how that ends.
And so my question to you is, for someone
right
now who is maybe working at a church or or
going to church,
but they
feel how how do they know if if they if
their path
is my is leading somewhere else?
Because maybe they're maybe the spirit is
kind of prompting them with something,
but they're like, ooh, I don't know.
I don't know. I think I should just keep
coming and doing the same thing
and and follow what everyone else is
doing.
Cause that seems that's what in it's
what's in front of me.
It's what everyone else is doing.
I the thought about going over here or
going over there is a little scary.
~ if someone is in that space right now
and they're listening to you,
what words of advice, what words of
wisdom,
what words of experience would you share
that would help them possibly kind
of navigate those waters when they might
be feeling God calling them
to do something that's not the
run-of-the-mill vanilla path?
Hmm, great question.
First thing I would say is that it's
important that we pay attention
to when the Holy Spirit is nudging us.
And one of the the ways I describe it is a
holy discontent.
It's like it's it's one of those things
where it's it's continuing to show up.
And it's like I it's not something where y
something's wrong,
but you just know that some is more.
And it keeps like there's breadcrumb
moments.
Like for some it might be like continuing
to just hear whether it's through
God using people or God continuing to put
it in your spirit that you're meant
to write a book or you see certain things
on the the news and you're just you're
outraged about something that you see
about a domestic violence survivor
or something happening in your community
and it's discontent around you feel like
I want to do something around it and it
won't leave you.
Those are signs.
That you should explore. You know,
when I'm talking to sisters and supporting
them in their discernment phase,
because this is really what we're talking
about here,
I invite them to reflect on three things.
First, I invite them to ask themselves:
what caused burden to you?
What is a cause that truly, when you see
it,
you're like, man, like I I want to make a
change.
I I'm I'm sick and tired of seeing people
struggle in my community.
I hate hearing stories about this,
whatever that is, is a cause that burdens
you.
Pay attention to that because that might
be a sign that you are,
you know, called to. Another thing that I
invite people to reflect on
is what gifts has God given you that could
be a service to this world?
That can meet some type of need,
right? That you're passionate about.
Exploring those gifts is something that
can really help you to see,
like, man, my ministry doesn't have to be
just used here.
It could be used in other places.
These gifts can actually make a difference
in my neighborhood or in the nation.
The other thing that I always like to
invite people to explore is who's your
tribe?
Who are the people who you are drawn to?
Are they drawn?
To you. And it might be the younger
version of yourself.
I think we're perfectly suited sometimes
to help the younger version
of ourselves with all the wisdom that we
get from our mistakes.
Yeah.
And from there, I just believe that none
of us,
when it comes to at least ministry,
is not confined to the four walls of the
church.
And so just take taking it out of the box
and being open to where
God is leading you. And even if you're
afraid,
even if you don't have it all right,
just making steps forward. You'll find
that God will show you your next step
and it'll be quite fulfilling.
I love that. You know, speaking of needs,
you said to notice, you know, what bothers
you?
What needs do you see in your world and
your community that really just kind
of sticks in your crawl and you just can't
quite let it go.
As I was reading your bio,
I I found myself wondering what needs that
you saw along the way that caused
you to want to create this business.
Because let me tell you, I know being an
entrepreneur is
Freaking hard. ~ it's it's scary.
Girl.
It's like jumping off a cliff and trying
to figure the parachute out
on the way down. And, you know,
talk about a journey of faith.
And so I'm wondering it for you,
like what need did you see in the women,
in whether it was in the in your
community,
in the world or whatever, that gave you
the drive and the motivation to create.
This business that you've created.
Mm, I'm going to
Be very vulnerable with you when it comes
to that question.
Because if you recall my answer a little
earlier,
I was saying helping the younger version
of yourself.
That was absolutely my motivation.
Having experienced sexual trauma in my
early 20s,
one of the things that I did to run from
my trauma was throw myself into ministry
and work and work and work. And that was
my addiction of choice.
And it was celebrated because it was like,
she's so dedicated. She's so, you know,
passionate.
But I was running for my pain and it was
showing up in my relationships.
I was, you know, showing up in how I led
as a leader of the nonprofit,
and it was messing things up. And finally,
I had to come to the realization,
girl, you got you need some therapy.
You need to do some work. Yes,
you got Jesus, but you can have Jesus and
a therapist.
And I had to I had to do the work and
start doing the work.
And I continue to do the work.
My therapist on speed dial now.
And and for me,
when I first started my my ministry,
which is called Faith on the Journey,
when I first started it as that blog,
when I was writing those stories about how
God helped people to heal from trauma.
I was really interviewing them for myself.
I wanted to hear, like, how did how did
you go through this healing journey?
Cause I'm still trying to heal.
So as I was interviewing people for the
blog,
as I was interviewing like over a hundred
people on my podcast about
the healing process, their stories was
helping me to heal.
And and so in that process of doing that,
the the the interviews, going to therapy
and
And really trying to walk out the healing
for myself,
I wanted to be able to show people the
same that yes,
our faith is is is core at our center,
but I believe that mental health practices
too are very important.
God uses people like therapists like you
to help us navigate our journey,
and that's important. And so that inspired
me to create that.
And the the other one other thing I want
to share is as while I
was building this ministry.
And it was really starting to take off.
And I was helping people to heal from
trauma.
I found myself in an abusive marriage.
And it was a dichotomy because I
was being traumatized behind closed doors
while trying to help other people heal
from trauma. And I really felt like I was
a fraud.
And you know, thank God I was able to get
out of that that that abusive marriage
and I had to really walk out the healing I
was teaching others.
This was again it was such a test because
I had to take time to set aside
to care for my own wounds so I wasn't
bleeding on other people and do all the
work.
But that also, now that I'm r removed from
the situation,
has really like put a like a fire.
Mm-hmm.
talk about a flame in in terms of my
passion to help people heal from trauma,
but also help other domestic violence
survivors to get the support they need
to know that abuse is not God.
And and so I speak very boldly about that
from my lived experience.
my gosh. Okay. So I've got two comments.
I'm gonna toss them out. You can do with
them whatever you want.
~ one of them is listening to you talk,
it reminded me so much of why I started my
podcast to begin with.
I actually started it in 2020 because I
wanted people to know you are not alone.
I was having so many people come into my
office and they were pouring out
all of the stuff.
All the pain, all the struggles,
all the fears. And they would just say,
you know, I just feel like it's I feel
like it's just me.
I feel like I'm the oddball out.
I'm the one that can't get my ish
together.
No, I can't that I'm the one.
But I would know that's not true because I
heard those stories every day,
day after day after day. But because of
confidentiality,
I'm not gonna, you know, you can't share
that stuff.
And so I thought, you know what?
If I started a podcast and we would have
people come on that was
That were willing to share their stories
and reach out.
Cause that's how I end my podcast is
saying,
you are not alone. Let people know they're
not alone so we can grow the community.
So I love that so much. And so my
question,
I have actually three things, I guess.
I made that comment. And then I have a
question of,
well, I'll wait a minute. I'm flipping,
I'm flipping it around. I'm gonna leave
the question till last.
I'm gonna make a second comment about.
the marriage and sometimes scripture can
be y can
be weaponized in marriages. And we both
know this.
We both exp and heard the stories,
all the things. And I and shout out to my
to my cousin Jill.
She listens to my podcast regularly.
She's supported me along the way and been
a big,
a big supporter. And she went through
something really bad with with
a husband who did that. And ~
That was just, you know, I'm not speaking
out of turn.
Everyone, you know, everyone in in the
community,
you know, was aware of of that kind of
thing going on.
And that's you get stuck because if
somebody doesn't have
a safe place that they can turn to and and
they have someone quoting them scripture
that, but but they're bastardizing it.
It's n they're weaponizing it,
they're bastardizing the scripture and
they're they're cherry picking.
So that's what that's what Jill went
through.
And I saw her and my heart hurt.
For her so much, and I'm so proud of how
far she's come.
And so that's a that's a comment.
And so I guess my question is kind of
related to that.
It's just like how, if someone were
listening right now or watching right now,
and they're in that scenario, what what
piece of information,
what would you want to share with them
that would help them have the courage to
get that information to go to therapy and
and quite frankly,
sometimes women they're afraid they're
going to get information that's going
to indicate they need to set a boundary.
And that's scary. You know,
in some scenarios, and I'm the queen of
boundaries,
right? I'm all about the boundaries.
I I've lived it. ~ and what's true of it
is sometimes in some scenarios
the even the thought
of setting a boundary with an individual
is scary because of the reaction that
is going to come. And so I was just kind
of wondering what your thoughts were
on on that in that area.
taking aside because this is such a heavy
question and whoever's listening
to this right now, particularly if you're
in this situation,
my heart goes out to you because I know
how hard it can be to even accept
the reality that you might be in an
abusive marriage or relationship.
You know, one of the things that I will
say is the the discovery of
the fact that you are being abused
sometimes is not always clear.
Because when it comes to abuse,
people for the most part understand it's
abuse if someone physically assaults
you or hits you. But there's a number of
other forms of abuse.
You were describing spiritual abuse when
someone tries to exert power
and control over you using scripture or
sacred text.
There's emotional abuse, financial abuse,
sexual abuse, legal abuse. There's all
different forms.
And sometimes it could be done in such a
manipulative way that you're left
confused. So one of the things that I do
encourage you
to do is discreetly,
because from a safety standpoint,
~ look into talking to someone who's
trained.
Okay, trained and who has ~ skills in this
area.
Why do I say it's important to talk
someone who's trained?
Because when it comes to domestic
violence,
there's a number of factors at play.
And first of all, we want to make sure
that whatever you're doing,
you're doing so in a way that will keep
you safe.
And so talking to someone who's trained
around that is important.
Also, sometimes there's good people in
your life who
They they care about you, but they could
be very misinformed.
And they could give you advice,
even if it's well intentioned,
who can actually re-traumatize you.
But like in the church
Mm-hmm. Yes.
or in whatever faith tradition,
sometimes people can try to make you
forgive too soon,
~ minimize what you're going through,
use scripture to have you stay in a
situation that's toxic.
So asking God for discernment and and
again,
maybe talking to the domestic violence
hotline or an agency and and
do so discreetly again is important.
important so that you can get some
objective feedback to say,
is this really abuse? Right? Because
sometimes you might dismiss it as,
~ they just have a temper or
Mm-hmm.
this is that or what no. Talk to someone
who knows and then they can guide you.
Or they're right, I'm wrong. You know,
they I'm wrong.
Exactly.
They're they they they know, you know,
they're smarter than me.
Mm-hmm. Yeah, and it's and that's tough.
~ but that would be the advice initially
that I would give for
a very complex question.
It
is, but you know, we're dealing with
complex stuff,
are we not? I
Mm.
mean, that's just that's how this stuff
goes.
And then when you're when you're going
through something like that,
it it a lot of gaslighting. And I know you
you treat women in in in in trauma.
And I, as you were talking, I remember
several times actually had to learn this
the hard way. How many things do we learn
the hard way?
~ but I learned
So
that
~ sometimes a controlling my experience
was it was a controlling husband.
It doesn't always have to be by any means,
but it was a controlling husband who was a
narcissistic person.
And he he tried to come and sort of
commandeer the therapy sessions.
So the wife would have an appointment with
me.
And he would call under the guise of,
and maybe he really believed this,
I don't know. Sometimes narcissists,
you they've they've drunk their own
Kool-Aid,
right? So ~ I'm just saying.
And so he would call and he under the
guise of,
you know, I want to make sure that you
understand,
you know, what what my wife is suffering.
And I think maybe if I came in for a
session,
then I could help really kind of flesh
out.
The information that you have so you can
help her better.
Now, I would like to say that I never fell
for that.
I cannot say that. In the very beginning,
when I was young and learning all the
things,
I fell for that. But I learned fast,
I'm a quick learner, and I quickly figured
out what was going on.
And then I'm a very direct person.
So then I I we address that in in therapy.
Unfortunately, you know, she did not come
back.
She was not ready to I mean, it's hard.
And and I'll make one other comment about
this,
about boundaries, and I'm gonna ask you
another quick kind of wrap it back around
to get your feedback is that guys,
when when we first started, when when
Reverend Jocelyn and I were trying
to get this podcast going today,
I could not get my headphones to work.
And just stay with me, I'm getting around
to the point.
So
I couldn't get my headphones to work.
And I tried and I tried. And with this,
I even got some old headphones and put
them on,
did all the things. And I'm like,
okay, I'm not stopping. I'm not effing
stopping.
I don't stop. I don't stop. I don't back
down.
And we finally got, we finally got it
going.
But the reason why I'm saying this is
because that's one of the reasons why,
as the queen of boundaries, it's like when
when you support someone,
it's like you you you get to the point
where,
okay.
I don't back down. And it's like if you if
you're in a relationship with someone
and you feel like you cannot say no.
You feel like your your opinion is
irrelevant.
The only opinion that matters is in the
relationship is the other person's.
if you offer an alternative point of view,
you're wrong. you can't ever say,
I don't want to do this, I want to do this
over here instead.
That's a form of a no.
If you're in a relationship like that and
you have to always back down,
back down, back down in favor of the other
person's opinions and their desires,
hello. You are being emotionally abused in
all likelihood.
So I just want to throw that out there.
~ and to be honest with you, in some
instances,
I think people would rather be physically
abused than emotionally abused,
because, well, there's pros and cons on
either way.
But with emotional abuse, there's a lot of
manipulation and lying.
And the abuser will sometimes go around
and go to
the friends and poison the poison the
friends and say say things to
the friends to try to isolate ~ the the
one who's being abused.
So I just wanted to kind of toss that out
in in,
you know, Reverend Jocelyn and in kind of
like piggybacking on what
you were saying earlier.
Well, let me first off start by saying
that your listeners couldn't see me,
but I was like clapping. I muted myself.
Well, the ones on YouTube can.
Yeah,
~ they can see. Okay, I didn't know they
could see me.
I was like, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's
right.
Yeah.
Because here's the thing that I know is
that when it comes
to boundaries to your point, that is
something that someone who i is
on the abusive side, they're abusive,
they are they absolutely hate that word.
It's like a curse word. Because that
that's getting in the way.
of them having power and control.
over you, which is really what abuse boils
down to.
And when it comes to abuse that's not
physical,
oftentimes it's just you're left so
doggone confused because you just can't
always
like there's not usually a witness to to
be able to and you're trying
to describe the state of confusion that
you have been left in
by the whole situation. Why did he just go
from zero?
Because it's not always a he, excuse my
language,
why did they just go from zero to this?
Or why is it
a thing when it shouldn't even be a thing
and it's just it's just confusing.
But it does have a major toll toll on you.
And when I was in my healing process,
I joined support groups for domestic
violence survivors.
And listening to those stories,
many of the women lost hair, health
issues,
like you know, all types of things was
happening because that type of duress
~ one of my girlfriends c called herself a
prisoner of war.
Like it felt like that. And being under
that chronic state of trauma.
It does something to you.
my gosh, you are a hundred percent right.
I mean, nail on the head, it just it beats
you down,
it wears you down. That's one of the
reasons why when I I train people about
boundaries, I love to use a yard analogy
because it makes it very easy
to understand. And I'm like, imagine you
have a yard,
and in your yard are your thoughts,
your feelings, and your actions.
These are things that belong to you.
This is where your agency lies.
These are things that you can change,
and these are things that you are
responsible for.
And then if you traipse across your grass,
you're going to run into a property line.
Now, on the other side of that property
line is your neighbor's yard,
okay? Your neighbor's thoughts,
feelings, and actions are in your
neighbor's yard and they don't belong to
you.
You cannot, you're not causing what your
neighbor is thinking,
feeling, or doing. You cannot control it,
and surely you cannot cure it.
That is a very simple analogy that I love
to train people in because when you're
in these relationships, frequently you get
blamed for when I say your partner,
your neighbor, that means your partner or
could be a coworker.
Anybody. Anybody that you're in
relationship with is your neighbor.
So frequently they're like, I wouldn't be
this mad if you wouldn't do such and such.
hail to the no is what I say to that.
Okay. This is my podcast, and I'll talk
how I want.
So
I'm like, no, if if if if he is ~ I'm
saying he,
it could be a she. I've heard these
stories too,
but just for brevity's sake, we'll just
say he.
So if he says, Well, I wouldn't be mad if
you if you hadn't come
in late or whatever, or if you hadn't used
whatever ~ first of all,
his emotion is in his brain.
And unless you have access to his brain,
you cannot cause him to feel anything.
So
That's why I love teaching boundaries and
and helping women understand,
okay, well, is it your thought?
Is it your feeling? Or is it someone
else's thought or feeling,
which they're gonna blame you for it,
but you're the one that needs to know it's
not yours,
it's on the other side of the property
line.
Hmm, that right there. Very important.
And I think once you start it once you
start realizing that and it clicks
and you see what's going on, that's where
the education piece is important.
Like saying, like, no, that was
manipulation.
No, that that had nothing to do with you.
And
Nope.
being able to call VS BS, you know,
and I but understanding too, in some
cases,
depending on the volatility of the
situation,
you also have to be wise and safe about is
what.
Well, because
Yes. Yes.
~ even with one thing I want to quickly
mention here,
too, is one of the things I found out when
it comes to domestic violence,
it's not even fully recommended that you
go to counseling,
particularly because like the person who's
being abused can get in trouble.
And I'm talking about marriage,
like counseling couples counseling.
~ because you can get in trouble for
telling on the person for being abusive,
like like the person, if the counselor,
the therapist is not trained to be able to
see what's happening when it comes to.
Domestic violence, kind of like the story
you were kind of mentioning earlier,
then they could absolutely be manipulated.
So it's one of those things where going
back to your question about
my recommendations, you educate yourself.
You, you know, talk to someone who's going
to help you to know your options
and develop a plan for.
I love this. Now, Reverend Jocelyn,
help me understand you you had a heart for
you have your programs.
Now let me look refer back to the the bio,
helping women gain clarity,
build structure, and confidently launch
and grow purpose-driven businesses.
So my question as I read that ~
description was.
These
women that you're helping grow
purpose-driven businesses,
what in general, when you look back,
what are their main pain points?
What are the things that these particular
women that are trying
to build purpose-driven businesses,
what do what does this particular niche of
women struggle with the most?
What
Hmm.
are you trying to help there?
Yeah, so I love working with women who see
what they're doing as a form of ministry.
Like for me, when I started my Christian
counseling company,
that's my ministry. You know, when I'm
doing trauma healing groups,
it's Christ centered groups. I'm doing
retreats at churches,
but it's ministry to me. But it also is
has a business structure because ministry
can be done through your business.
And so I am called to work with women who
want to do the same.
The women who I work with though often
struggle
With that dichotomy of okay, faith and
business,
like ministry and money. Like,
how do I structure this in a way where I'm
honoring my faith in God,
but I also make this sustainable?
I'm the type that'll give everything away
for free forever.
And and the God bless you for your heart.
If you're looking to do this as a
business,
though, how can we still set this up where
there is a financial engine
to support the business?
The business so that you're not like going
into a whole bunch of debt
and your mission can move forward.
So, what I help women do, those
heart-centered women out there who feel
called
to build the nonprofits, to be Christian
coaches,
to be speakers, I help them to honor their
core,
their faith, but also set their kingdom
business up in a way that has
a plan that's sustainable, so they can
reach the people who are their assignment.
I love this a lot and I know our time is
about up,
but I wanted to to make a comment about
that and then also make sure that
all of the listeners and viewers can find
you,
can get access to you. And we're gonna
talk about your two books as well.
And you have a podcast that I'm gonna be
guesting on tomorrow,
Yes. I'm I'm very excited.
I think. This is gonna be so much fun.
We could have some more time together,
Josh.
So I think it's really interesting because
I I'm I told you I'm
an entrepreneur and I'm in a speaking
business as well.
And so
It's it's it's an under it's understood
that in general,
I'm stereotyping here, but in general,
people expect our culture expects men to
charge.
They expect women to do the same thing for
free or for much reduced amount
of money. This is not okay. If you have
both people that are doing their business
and and it whether it's ministry or
whatever it is,
and it's not, you know, there needs to be
more.
gender equity there. So I'm so glad you're
supporting the women and
and helping them to understand with
business there are expenses.
If you want to continue, if you want to,
if you want the same way with boundaries,
like if you want to do it, I help people
play the long game.
If you want to play the long game,
like I I work with high performers who
burn out.
If you want to play the long game and not
burn out,
you better figure out boundaries now or
you're going to gas out,
girlfriend, right? Same way with money,
right? If you don't
Businesses, there are expenses that we
have to keep it going.
We have to pay money out initially to get
things going along.
If we go somewhere, there's, you know,
you have to pay for the plane tickets,
you have to pay for the lodging,
you have to pay for Uber, you have to pay
for the meals.
And that's just the travel. That's not
talking about what it costs.
Like for you, you have two books.
You had to initially invest, right?
Yes.
You know, that just doesn't somebody
doesn't just plop a book on your lap for
free.
No, you have to invest. You have to pay
people to help you to do that,
to publish, to put it together,
to distribute it, all the things.
There's so we as women, we have to develop
in my mind,
and it feels seems like you're like-minded
in this,
and this is what you're doing for these
women,
helping them to understand.
Get your head straight in this.
This is you need to be able to charge so
that your business,
so that your ministry can can keep going.
If you're not charging money, if you're
not collecting fees,
then you're not you're gonna gas out,
just like with boundaries. You're not
gonna you're not gonna make it.
You're not gonna have the money for your
business to sustain if you're
if you don't get comfortable charging for
what you're providing.
Absolutely. If it's a service,
just like the the difference between a
Christian therapist and a
~ therapist who's not overtly advertising
as Christian,
is the service. You're providing a
valuable service,
a transformation. So charge your worth,
charge your value.
Yes, a hundred percent. That's it.
I mean, whether you're Christian or not
Christian shouldn't I mean it's that's
interesting. That's a that's a descriptor.
But that doesn't say, because I'm
Christian,
that means I'm not going to charge any
money.
That
Mm-hmm.
no, because it's not about the money.
The money is re reinvested back into the
business so that you can keep that going.
And it's just that's it's a business.
So I as you can tell, I'm a little bit on
my soapbox about that right now,
I love it. We we
Reverend Jocelyn.
could be on a soapbox together.
All right. So I'm looking down.
Where is it that you want people to go?
If they want, I know. Well, first of all,
you have two books. One Sister Start Your
Ministry.
That's
Hey, ~ yes.
the first book. And then Breaking the
Power of the Mask.
Ooh. Ooh, that sounds interesting.
So where do people go?
I know there's listeners and there's
viewers on YouTube.
That are thinking, my goodness,
this is just the tip of the iceberg.
I have got to get a hold of Reverend
Jocelyn Jones and find out more about this
woman. Where do they go?
Well, I'm mostly Rev Jocelyn everything.
So you can go to RevJoclin, R E V,
Jocelyn.com. My website has all my social
media.
YouTube. I'm like I live on YouTube.
So find me at Revostelin, subscribe there.
But if you go to Revjocelyn.com,
for those who are looking to start their
ministry,
you'll see like a option that pops up for
you to get a free ministry launch starter
kit that's going to literally,
if you feel called to build that ministry
beyond the walls of the church.
church is going to help you to get started
and take your next step.
So that's my free gift for your listeners.
I love that. That's fantastic.
Rev Jocelyn, thank you so much for
spending your precious time
and your expertise and your energy to be
here with me and all the Phoenix
and Flame community. Thank you,
thank you so much.
It's been a joy. This has been a wonderful
conversation.
Thank you for having me.
This is fun listeners. Okay, now I know
that you've heard multiple things today
that
you're thinking, I know of a friend,
I know of a relative, I know of a coworker
that needs to hear exactly this.
Take this episode, copy and paste it,
send it in text, send it in email,
take this episode and post it on your
favorite social media sites so we
can grow our Phoenix inflame community and
let people know you are not alone.
I hope your day's been going great.
I hope the rest of it is fantastic.
I'm Dana on Phoenix and Flame.